vous avez pas seulement les armes non
létales qui a incité policier a tiré
plus mais vous avez aussi une
utilisation très politique des forces de
l'ordre et les faits il est très clair
c'est que bas à force de se faire tirer
dessus
la population et les hits et se protège
lé porte de l'unef des foulards c'est
palace in de casseurs c'est d'ailleurs
tout simplement le film que on a plutôt
un peur de se faire agresser de se faire
mutiler et donc vous avez une
utilisation politique effectivement de
la police qui vise à dissuader et c'est
d'ailleurs pas seulement les forces de
l'ordre c'est quand même aussi un
élément assez inédit qu'on voit que le
nombre de gardes à vue donc
les gardes à vue a augmenté de façon
considérable au bout de quelques moins
de gilet jaune on avait plus de 4000
garde à vue alors si vous revenez un peu
en arrière en 2006 pendant le cpe le
nombre de 4500 c'était le nombre
d'interpellations et c'est déjà
considéré comme un niveau historiquement
élevé de répression est bien là info à
un seuil a été franchi
maintenant ce sont des gardes à vue qui
souvent sont accompagnés très très vite
un de condamnation ce qui d'ailleurs
impose un écart assez frappant entre les
policiers auteurs de tirs mutilant qu'on
retrouve rarement alors que bâle et
gilet jaune qui aurait cassé ceci ou
cela mahut sont condamnés très vite donc
on a même a aussi au niveau de la
justice un deux poids deux mesures qui
assez fringants flagrant
[Musique]